er hat die Justiz beschäftigt weil es
ein ganz spezielles Problem war nämlich
wie zu bewerten ist wenn ein Opfer
eigentlich sich selbst versucht
umzubringen tatsächlich aber von einer
anderen Person durch eine absurde
Geschichte dazu gebracht wird in die
Rechtsgeschichte ist er eben darüber
hinaus eingegangen weil die Person der
Täter der spätere Angeklagte sich als
Abgesandter des sternsirius dargestellt
hat gegenüber dem späteren Opfer und das
eine so absurde Geschichte ist wie man
sie sich kaum besser einbilden
kann das ist die Stimme von Professor
Martin Heger einem der wichtigsten
deutschen Experten für das Strafrecht er
lert Jura an der humbolduni in Berlin
und der heutige Fall der sich vor mehr
als 40 Jahren ereignet hat der gehört
regelmäßig zu seinem Kursplan denn er
ist gleichermaßen spannend wie knifflig
und spannenderweise gibt es sogar neue
Erkenntnisse über diese Geschichte und
damit hallo und herzlich Willkommen ich
bin Mirko kimir und bei mir ist die
wundervolle Tony haer hallo zusammen und
wir freuen uns natürlich dass ihr heute
auch wieder mit dabei
seid Tatort Deutschland die von
Bild unsere Geschichte beginnt im Jahr
1973 in Baden-Württemberg die 28-Jährige
Heidrun t geht in eine Disco Heidrun ist
Sekretärin und alleinstehend sie hat
kaum Freunde und gilt unter Kollegen als
schüchtern und schwierig Heidrun soll
unselbständig und voller komplexe
gewesen sein aber an diesem Abend
passiert etwas Spannendes Heidrun lernt
Fried Gaster kennen und findet ihn auf
anhiebklasse Fred ist etwa 4er Jahre
älter und stellt sich als Heilpraktiker
Privatdozent und Doktor der Psychologie
vor er interessiere sich für Hypnose und
Parapsychologie außerdem habe er
Verbindungen ins
Jenseits der Beginn einer scheinbar
wunderbaren Freundschaft über mehrere
Jahre wird Fred Heidrun vertrauter und
auch Lebensberater alle paar Monate
sehen sich die beiden bei ihm in
badenbaden oder bei ihrem Städtchen
badwi im Norden des Schwarzwaldes
meistens aber telefonieren sie
hedrun sucht ihren Weg und den Sinn des
Lebens und Fred hilft nur allzu gern er
philosophiert mit ihr stundenlang über
Religion den Tod Wiedergeburt oder die
Weiterentwicklung der eigenen göttlichen
Seele um Sex geht es höchstens am Rande
dafür geht es irgendwann um Geld denn im
Laufe vieler Gespräche verret Fred
seiner Freundin Heidrun Atem beraubende
Geheimnisse in Wahrheit nämlich sei er
ein Bewohner des Sterns Sirius und die
sirrianer sein in eine Rasse die
philosophisch auf einer weit höheren
Stufe stehen als die Menschen er sei mit
dem Auftrag auf die Erde gesandt worden
dafür zu sorgen dass einige wertvolle
Menschen darunter eben auch hedruh nach
dem völligen Zerfall ihrer Körper mit
ihrer Seele auf einem anderen Planeten
oder dem Sirius weiterleben
könnten
wow also das muss ich erstmal kurz
sacken lassen da hat die gute hedrun
ernsthaften echten Sirianer
kennengelernt nutzen wir mal diese kurze
Verschnaufspause um ein ganz bisschen
was zu lernen über den Sirius und dafür
schalten wir jetzt mal den
Deutschlandfunk ein Sirius hellster
Stern ohne
Rätsel in den späten Abendstunden
funkelt im Süden ein blauweiß rötlicher
Stern Sirius im großen Hund der hellste
Stern am Nachthimmel er hat etwa die
doppelte Sonnenmasse und sendet 25 mal
mehr Strahlung aus als unsere Sonne dass
er unseren Himmel dominiert liegt vor
allem an der geringen Entfernung von
nicht einmal neuen Lichtjahren Sirius
gehört zu unseren zehn nächsten
nachbarsternen dieser Stern Sirius a hat
übrigens noch einen kleinen Bruder einen
sogenannten weißen Zwerg namens Sirius B
und natürlich könnten wir euch hier noch
viel mehr über die Sonnen erzählen aber
eins dürfte schon deutlich geworden sein
selbst wenn man an Außerirdische glaubt
ist es sehr unwahrscheinlich dass jemand
auf der tausende Grad heißen Oberfläche
dieses Sterns leben könnte ja aber das
scheint heidrung gar nicht zu stören sie
nimmt Fred noch weitere fantastische
Dinge ab es sei tatsächlich so dass es
noch eine kompetentere Instanz als ihn
also Fred gebe nämlich den Mönch uliko
worauf Fred hier zusteuert das kann
Strafrechtler Martin Heger super
zusammenfassen dem Täter ging es
eigentlich darum Geld zu bekommen er
wollte dass er durch Vorspiegelung einer
absurden Geschichte für das Opfer dieses
dazu bringt sich umzubringen in einer
Weise dass Lebensversicherungen die
davor abgeschlossen worden sind fällig
werden und diese der Täter kassieren
will das ist die harte Geschichte
dahinter tatsächlich hat aber der Täter
sich als Abgesandter des Sterns Sirius
ausgegeben und dem Opfer gesagt er
könnte ihr sie war Sekretärin und
irgendwie in der präkären Situation ein
besseres Leben auf dem Stern Sirius
verschaffen und dafür bräuchte sie aber
natürlich Geld und er bräuchte einen
Helfer einen Mönch der da Kontakte hätte
und alles das würde Geld kosten und er
würde ihr da helfen aber sie müsste sich
letzt ich umbringen aber eben in einer
Weise dass das nicht als Selbstmord
erscheint sondern als Unfall weil sonst
eine Lebensversicherung nicht zahlen
würde und das Geld das würde man dann
nehmen damit sie eben zum Stein Sirius
kommt dort besser lebt und um
dorthinzukommen müsste sie sich außerdem
quasi ihrer weltlichen Kleider das heißt
ihrer Haut ihrer Knochen und so weiter
entledigen sie würde also nur als
geistiges Wesen dorthin kommen aber
irgendwie Geld brauchte man wohl
trotzdem dort und vor diesem Hintergrund
sollte sie einen Unfall machen
vermeintlich indem Sie den föen in die
Badewanne fallen lässt und dadurch eben
einen elektrischen Schlag bekommt und
stirbt und dann wäre das der
Versicherung gemeldet worden und
begünstigter des Versicherungsvertrags
war dieser angebliche Abgesandte vom
Stern Sirius der hätte also dann die
Prämie das Geld
kassiert was Martin Heger hier auf den
Punkt bringt schauen wir uns jetzt mal
genauer an damit Heidrun aber als
höheres Wesen zum Sirius übersiedeln
kann erklärt ihr Fred müsse sich Mönch
uliko für einige Zeit in totale
Meditation versetzen was auch sehr gern
tue aber das koste 30 000 Mark die
ulikus Kloster für die Unkosten
benötige mit Hilfe der gedankenübung des
Mönches werde es ihrem Körper dann
möglich sein während des Schlaf
mehrere Ebenen zu durchlaufen und dabei
eine geistige Entwicklung
durchzumachen logisch denkt sich Heidrun
nimmt einen entsprechenden Kredit auf
und lässt die Kohle Fred zuukommen in
den folgenden Monaten erkundigt sie sich
immer wieder bei ihm nach den
Fortschritten aber was soll ich sagen es
handelt sich um eine wirklich schwierige
Meditation die oliko da versucht sie ist
sogar gefährlich für IKO erklärt Fried
ihr und schließlich muss er einräumen
das Projekt ist gescheitert
iKOS Meditation führten nicht zum Sirius
und Schuld sei letztendlich Heidrun
selbst muss sie erfahren denn in ihrem
Bewusstsein gäbe es eine zu starke
Sperre gegen die Umsiedlung ihres
Geistes aber zum Glück hat Fred noch
einen Plan B die Blockade müsse umgangen
werden indem Heidrun ihren alten Körper
verlässt in einem roten Raum am genfere
stehe für sie ein neuer Körper bereit
indem sie sich als wiederfinden werde
vorher aber müsse sie sich von ihrem
alten Körper
trennen und wie schon der erste Plan
kostet auch diese neue Idee leider Geld
aber auch dafür hat Fred Gaster eine
Idee Heidrun solle doch eine
Lebensversicherung abschließen die bei
einem Unfalltod eine Auszahlung über 500
000 Mark vorsieht zu leisten natürlich
an ihn unseren guten alten Freund Fred
als Heron genau eine solche Versicherung
abgeschlossen hat muss nur noch ein
Unfall passieren erst tendiert freed zu
einem Autounfall aber schließlich
berichtet er hydrun von einer
einfacheren Idee ihr solle ein Fön in
die Badewanne fallen in den
Wintermonaten des Jahres
1979 beginnen die letzten Vorbereitungen
zusätzlich zur abgeschlossenen
Lebensversicherung soll hedr und Fred
noch 4000 Mark überweisen als soofthilfe
damit er ihr mit Barem helfen kann wenn
sie in Genf in ihrem neuen Körper
aufwacht
damit Heidrun Tod am 1 Januar 1980 auch
wirklich wie ein Unfall und nicht wie
ein Selbstmord aussieht denken sich die
beiden eine Art Programm aus Heidrun
lädt für den Nachmittag eine Freundin in
Ihre Wohnung in Bad Wildbad zum Kaffee
ein putzt die Wohnung backt einen Kuchen
dann legt sie sich in die Wande und
lässt schließlich den Föhn der an die
Steckdose angeschlossen ist ins Wasser
fallen es
passiert
nichts Fred der diesen Tag bei sich zu
Hause in badenbaden verbringt wundert
sich als Heidrun anruft sie habe alles
gemacht wie besprochen aber es sei kein
Stromschlag erfolgt unter Freds
Anleitung wiederholt sie den Versuch
noch ein paar Mal aber es gibt keinen
Knall keinen Kurzschluss keinen
Stromschlag und erst recht keinen Tod
das wundert mich jetzt schon ein
bisschen weil eigentlich lernt doch
jeder oder jedes Kind irgendwann dass
man kein föhen in die Nähe der gefüllten
Badewanne lassen soll ah Tony so wie ich
das aus den Gerichtsprotokollen
herauslese war das Haus angeblich
mangelhaft geerdet das heißt es konnte
sich kein tödlicher Stromkreislauf
bilden wie das eigentlich passieren
würde also von der Steckdose durch das
Kabel in den föhen und im Wasser durch
hydrons Körper und die Erdung hindurch
dann hätte ihr Herz unter der Stromlast
kollabieren müssen so aber ohne Erdung
floss einfach gar kein Strom durch die
Wanne okay also es passt t eben nichts
und Fred gibt irgendwann entnervt auf
wie aber wurde sein teuflischer Plan
dann bekannt dazu Martin Heger eine
Freundin der Frau der wurde das wohl
davor gesagt die hat dann am Ende das
bei der Polizei angemeldet die hat diese
Geschichte also nicht geglaubt die hat
geglaubt was es wirklich ist ein
dreister betrug der immerhin mit dem
Leben des Opfers spielt nicht bloß Geld
will vom Opfer oder von dessen Sicherung
sondern als Voraussetzung davon den Tod
des Opfers einkalkuliert hat deshalb
wurde das Ganze eben aktenkundig
angezeigt die Polizei hat dann ermittelt
und dann befragt man natürlich die
Zeugen in dem Falle eben die die sich
selbst töten wollte und so kam dann die
Geschichte raus bis zu offiziellen
Ermittlungen dauert es aber noch bis zum
August
1980 der Prozess gegen Fred Gaster wird
schließlich vor dem Landgericht
badenbaden geführt und ich meine das
muss schon damals für die Beteiligten
spannt gewesen sein obwohl sie
wahrscheinlich nicht wussten dass sie
Rechtsgeschichte schreiben wenn ich
jetzt sage Mirko spring aus dem 19 Stock
des springerhochhauses und du springst
bin ich dann eine Mörderin obwohl du so
entschuldigung dass ich sage du so blöd
bist so etwas zu tun Jura Professor
Heger dröselt das für uns mal auf lange
wurde darüber diskutiert ob man einen
Betrug einen strafbaren betrug auch dann
nimmt wenn jemand eigentlich viel zu
leichtgläubig für diese Welt ist also ob
dieser tatband auch den blödesten oder
dümmsten schützt und die Rechtssprechung
hat dann in diesem Urteil und in ein
paar anderen Fällen die nicht ganz so
blutig waren aber bei denen es auch um
Leichtgläubigkeit ging jeweils gesagt
der Betrugstatbestand des deutschen
Strafrechts schützt jeden vor Täuschung
auch wenn man diese Täuschung eigentlich
leicht durchschauen müsste wer also im
truen auf eine Täuschung auf die
Wahrheit dieser Täuschung einem anderen
Geld gibt oder eine Versicherung
vermittelt oder sich gar mit seinem
Leben opfert ist durch den
Betrugstatbestand in Deutschland
vollumfänglich geschützt es gibt also
auch einen Schutz für die dümmsten und
das ist wohl auch konsequent zwar soll
das Strafrecht nicht alles und jeden
bestrafen aber natürlich gerade die
Leute schützen die sich nicht selbst
schützen können und dazu gehören auch
die die einer Täuschung auf den Leim
gehen weil sie zu leichtgläubig oder zu
dumm sind um das zu durchschauen die
Anklage betont dass Heidrun den Betrug
nicht ahnte und auch keinen Selbstmord
begehen wollte sie dachte sie würde mit
Hilfe des Föhns in der Wanne quasi in
ein anderes Leben schlüpfen das einer
Künstlerin in Genf Fred wiederum sei
völlig klar gewesen dass Heidrun sich
umbringen würde und er von ihr Geld
erhalten würde und so fällt erst das
Landgericht und dann in der Revision der
BGH das Urteil das bis heute so viele
beschäftigt noch mal Professor Heger die
Pointe dieses Falles war dass neben dem
Betrug der natürlich hier in Rede stand
und bejahrt wurde der Bundesgerichtshof
gesagt hat es ist auch ein versuchter
Mord und das war spektakulär weil man
davor und bis heute eigentlich immer
sagt wer sich selbst umbringt oder auch
versucht sich selbst umzubringen ist
nicht strafbar mit der Konsequenz dass
auch derjenige der ihm dabei hilft nicht
wegen Beihilfe zum versuchten oder
vollendeten Mord strafbar ist oder wer
ihn anstiftet nach dem Motto bring dich
um der ist nicht wegen Anstiftung zum
Mord oder wie hier versuchten Mord
strafbar eigentlich aber der
Bundesgerichtshof hat gesagt hier sei
das anders weil sich das leichtgläubige
Opfer das diese komische Geschichte
geglaubt hat hat nicht eigentlich
umbringen wollte sondern ja weiterleben
wollte wenn gleich durch eine wie auch
immer eine Vergeistigung auf einem
anderen Stern und deshalb hat sie
eigentlich nicht als Selbstmörderin im
eigentlichen Sinne gehandelt sondern sie
war das gutgläubige Werkzeug eines
Hintermannes der ihr diese Geschichte
eingeredet hat nämlich dem Täter der
angeblich vom stanirius war und dieser
wurde dann also auch nicht nur wegen
Anstiftung zum Mord oder zum versuchten
Mord verurteilt sondern wegen versuchten
Mordes in mittelbarer Täterschaft er hat
sozusagen das Opfer genutzt gegen sich
selbst um sich selbst umzubringen und
damit so die Auffassung der
Rechtsprechung eigentlich selbst einen
Mord begangen durch das Opfer an sich
selbst Gaster kommt für Jahre ins
Gefängnis und damit wäre die Geschichte
eigentlich auserzählt aber Jahre später
kommt ein fürchterlicher Verdacht auf
einer der eigentlich nahe liegt war
Heidrun t die einzige die Fred so
geschickt und skrupellos manipuliert hat
oder gab es weitere Fälle das fragen
sich 2022 der exrichter Thomas Fischer
und der ARD Journalist Holger Schmidt
und ihre Antworten sind krass vieles
spricht dafür dass ein Serienmörder war
es gibt beispielsweise die Geschichte
einer gewissen Angela die auf gerader
Strecke bei besten Wetter gegen einen
Baum fährt kurz nachdem Sie Fred
getroffen hat es gibt eine Margarete die
einen grausamen Flammentod stirbt auch
mindestens zwei männliche Freunde von
Fred kommen auf rätselhafte Weise um
mindestens einmal wurde deshalb auch
gegen ihn
ermittelt in ihrer TV Dooku und dem
Podcast berichten Schmidt und Fischer
auch noch mal vom unerklärlichen Suizid
von Gass Frau Heike sie hat sich nur
vier Wochen vor dem badewannengeschehen
zu Hause auf dem Sofa erschossen die
Links zum Podcast der ARD Kollegen den
findet ihr natürlich in den Show nototes
hört unbedingt mal rein auch den
Radiobeitrag des Deutschlandfunks zum
Stern Sirius den verlinken wir euch
natürlich und damit sind wir auch schon
fast am Ende Fred Gaster versuchte aus
dem Gefängnis heraus noch weitere
Betrugsmaschen wurde dabei aber erwischt
dadurch verlängerte sich seine Haft bis
1990 an Weihnachten
1996 wurde er tot in seiner Wohnung
aufgefunden und anonym in Neumünster
bestattet Heidrun so haben es die ARD
Kollegen recherchiert trat 1993 noch mal
in einer NDR Talkshow auf sie arbeitete
damals als
Heilpraktikerin heute ist sie natürlich
eine ältere Frau und lebt laut Schmidt
und Fischer in einer Art warnwelt auch
was den alten Fall angeht und damit sind
wir am Ende unserer heutigen Ausgabe
angelangt wir danken euch dass ihr
wieder mit dabei wart und freuen uns
über Anregungen Lob und Kritik von euch
und dafür könnt ihr uns gerne eine Mail
schicken oder uns bei Instagram
schreiben wir freuen uns von euch zu
hören das skriipt für die heutige
Ausgabe hat Stefan nitzeband geschrieben
Schnitt Lilli von der Osten
Postproduktion durch schwarzudio Berlin
und wir danken natürlich auch Professor
higer für seine Einordnungen bald wird
auch helfen den Fall des sogenannten
kudamrasers besser zu verstehen und
damit bis zur nächsten Episode eure Toni
und euer Mirko ciao
ciao die hat diese Folge von tatout
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Reusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Führung von ursela
Herrmann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland